Georgia Tech is the first university
to offer a FHIR platform for
students to develop and
test their innovative ideas.
It provides access to
synthetic health data for
some 10,000 make believe chronic
disease patients like Marla.
You access that data using
some key FHIR resources, for
which we've implemented the ability,
with some limitations,
to create, read, update,
and delete, called CRUD.
You'll also have access to
the SMART on FHIR app platform.
You'll form teams,
each of which will turn its innovation
into at least a working prototype using
FHIR as the source of patient data.
Each team will be assigned to a TA,
who will help resolve any technical
issues and answer any questions.
If you want one, we'll try and
connect you with a domain expert
relevant to your project.
It's important that each team have
people with the right set of skills.
So we'll be providing assistance
to you to form effective teams.
We'll discuss FHIR in lesson 5B, but
I suggest you get started exploring it
now by visiting the websites I've
listed in the instructor's notes.